Congratulations on getting
through all the lessons.
Along the way,
I hope you've thought about what it
would take to build your own mobile app.
And maybe you've had some good ideas for
a really big project,
something that you think would be
successful, or fun to build, or
a project to scratch your own itch.
Now if you've enrolled in the full
course experience, then you have access
to project evaluations and
code review by our Udacity coaches.
They want to help you build
a great mobile web app.
Now in the instructor comments
below this video, you'll
see a link to the rubric that they'll
be using to evaluate your project.
You should take a look at it so
you know what they'll be looking for.
You'll also find a link
to an example app.
We've provided this in case you're
not sure what app you want to build.
If so, then just try building your
own version of that example app.
If you're still unclear,
then talk to your coach.
They're here to help you succeed
in this course and in your career.